a push number three is to think about
like we thought first about the letter D
right and then here we tried to think
about them together right
did you notice like when I said this you
speak yeah okay Swan over here once you
place the letter D it can be any way
it's kind of like one of the other guys
okay well I'm gonna try and take a
similar approach to positioning the
letter D let's just say D can be
anywhere in fact it's kind of what we
did with approach one right as I I can
put D wherever I like so therefore if I
treat D is a regular letter we'll leave
in for say if I treat D is a regular
letter how many ways are there to place
D and all of the normal letters there 8
factorial right so you've got your first
the first box that you've got there
right you might no harm it's a bit hard
to do because adequately it's 89 look
the same okay you've got eight slots
there okay so first I'm just going to
place all these other letters right so
place eight letters including the letter
D okay so this is now have you look at
the next event the letter M now has to
go in somewhere okay
how many spots kidding good well what
you can do is you can take your letter n
right let's just say this is your letter
N and you can just kind of jam it in
somewhere in this existing word right so
I could put it here on the end or I
could write it right here in the middle
or wherever I like okay now you can see
what the next diagram is there are nine
of these spots in which I could place
that letter in does that make sense and
I've put them in as those gray one too
nice
okay so I could put it in any one of
those spots kind of all right I actually
can't put it in any of those spots
because based on where D is this is very
similar to this - based on where D is
some of those spots will not meet my
condition okay so when you have a look
remember remember there are eight
factorial ways here so D can be in eight
spots do you see
similar to this here we are there a nine
spot but one of the ends up being done
well here there are only eight spots for
the deer you go into you it's it's fine
now some of them are okay for here and
some of them are not now I'm just gonna
use this because um
it'll take me too long to draw you've
already got it have a look at this D can
be in any one of those eight spots but
depending on where D is that makes some
spots okay and some spots not okay for
him does that make sense so you can see
over here this is kind of another way of
approaching number one right I know you
would not have the joys but I just want
to illustrate for you so you can see in
front of you right depending on where
two years you'll have these spots in
green that are acceptable for em and
once you place it like this in the same
way that I've argued from symmetry here
clearly those spots for EM that are okay
exactly match the numbers what's in that
odds okay half a good part about right
so that's another way for me be able to
say okay we give all the spots this is
all the spots but only one half of them
okay you can see this is a totally
different way of establishing what's
going on versus this right the argument
is quite different what I still arrive
at the same answer because if D is in
the eighth position in my original
eights buyers
that's okay so if the is there well I
can always put in like right on the air
intake okay I could always do that
because it will be to the right of deep
wherever D might be which is why it's
always great okay so maybe instead of
maybe don't know green maybe can just
boutiques on these months so you can see
like you can make your visualize with
what tough huh well you placed d the
white are the boxes with your original
eight letters are right remember you
placed all of the letters except for end
are you placed all of them and we said
well there's eight factorial ways but
all of these guys to be filling in
I just haven't written what those
letters are because they could be
anything right but based on where D is
that tells you you can put in in these
spots in between so your for D for n
rather you're thinking about these gaps
remember right you've positioned all of
the other letters let me just give you
an example let's talk about the first
one right so you've got well that's just
right decisions without an M right so
okay like that and then now I asked the
question well where would you like em to
go looks like m to go right and and I
could say well I can I can stick it in
there that would be gap number one sorry
one two three four that's the fourth gap
over there or I could stick in there or
there only place I can stick in is here
I can't do that because it wouldn't
satisfy my condition okay which is why
one position one or gap one rather is
never green it'll never be an option
okay no how do you sort of flex your
muscles for thinking like this
my advice is whenever you get like these
are fiction questions with conditions
that are ones get your treatment right
as much as possible when you do a
question Joe just arrived a number and
if the same is the young text
do the question again at least there's
usually at least one other way you could
think about this problem okay and if you
start to not just solve it then move on
like there's no prostitution I can
arrive at if you can go with the same
number in another way my noticing
patterns like this you look at number
you like her is that right
hope you like noticing that this was
hard is what gave me the other two
arguments right the other two ways to
approach err